[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 20 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les titres de ce mercredi 28
octobre après une reprise lente
l'économie va t'elle subir une deuxième
vague de récession la question se pose
avec un recond finement potentiel le
président de la république s'exprime ce
soir le gouvernement a d'ores et déjà
annoncé de nouvelles aides pour les
entreprises nous ferons le point et
invités de cette édition aymeric de la
boissière président de la fédération
bancaire française yvelines en cette
période les méthodes de travail doivent
aussi se réinventer c'est pourquoi la
solution du coworking pourrait avoir le
vent en poupe un nouvel espace a ouvert
depuis un mois sans cyr l'école ses
utilisateurs suit les bureaux et les
transports en commun bondés et puis le
paris saint germain joue ce soir la
deuxième journée de la ligue des
champions face à istanbul basaksehir en
attendant la fondation psg installé hier
son village chez nero concours au menu
activités sportives pendant les vacances
tout à l'heure la suite également de
notre dossier sur le circuit court et
vous le verrez la vallée de chevreuse en
plus de sa monnaie a également son eau
minérale
[Musique]
la france entière suspendue aux lèvres
des manuels macron le président de la
république doit s'exprimer ce soir à
partir de 20 heures pour annoncer de
nouvelles mesures l'objectif faire face
à la deuxième vague de kobe de 19 qui a
sévi dans le pays et dans les yvelines
le département enregistré hier quatre
décès si réanimation et 24
hospitalisations supplémentaires
et d'après plusieurs sources 1re
confinement national d'une durée de
quatre semaines minimum est évoquée avec
des écoles et collèges toujours ouvert
des cours à distance pour les
universités voire pour les lycées et du
télétravail renforcé pour les
entreprises la locution je vous le
rappelle est prévue à partir de 20
heures
la deuxième vague de kobe dix neuf at
elle engendre est aussi une seconde
vague au niveau économique l'impact et
gatti est négatif du premier confinement
elle nous amène à nous poser la question
on en parle avec deux personnes en
plateau nicolas landry bonsoir bonsoir
de la rédaction tv 78 dans un instant
vous allez nous parler des différentes
aides pour les entreprises afin de
limiter les dégâts qu'elles soient
nouvelles d'ailleurs où qu'elle soit
prolongée
ces aides est également avec nous et
aymeric de la boissière bon soir en soir
président du comité des banques des
yvelines de la fédération bancaire
française c'est l'organisation
professionnelle qui représente toutes
les banques installées en france est
d'abord cette actualité la france les
yvelines qui se dirige vers un nouveau
confinement un confinement sans doute
plus léger que le premier auquel on a pu
assister et est ce que c'est de nature à
vous inquiéter
ah oui il nous sommes un peu comme comme
tout le monde dans l'expectative on
attend un peu de savoir à quelle sauce
on va être mangé si on avait pu faire
face à la première crise avec les pg e
tout comme les chefs d'entreprise on
n'aime pas beaucoup ne pas savoir où on
va et on aimerait bien
chose la plus légère possible pour
permettre à l'activité et aux commerces
de continuer à fonctionner l'épée jeu
ainsi des prêts garantis par l'état
justement nicolas landry dans ce
contexte de renforcement des mesures de
restriction le gouvernement a renforcé
des dispositifs d aide aux entreprises
vous fait le point pour tv 70
effectivement grégory il va utiliser les
mêmes recettes utilisées lors du
confinement
ils vont être prolongées sont déjà à
prolonger et vont peut-être être
renforcée suite aux annonces du
président de la république ce soir
l'activité partielle va être maintenu au
moins jusqu'au 31 décembre avec une
prise en charge par l'état à hauteur de
84 % du salaire net
les entreprises touchées par les
restrictions sanitaires pourront en
bénéficier et certains secteurs comme
l'hôtellerie ou la restauration conserve
la prise en charge intégrale par l'état
le fonds de solidarité est aussi
prolongé jusqu'au 31 décembre il
concerne les tpe les indépendants les
micro entrepreneurs et les professions
libérales il est élargi aussi aux
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
impactés par les restrictions sanitaires
et dernier exemple l'état a aussi
reporter les échéances sociales et
fiscales pour les entreprises les plus
en difficulté non il existe aussi des
aides de la région et de saint quentin
en yvelines et ces aides sont toujours
actives effectivement grégory alors
plusieurs dispositifs j'en ai
sélectionné une un dispositif pardon la
région ile-de-france a notamment
renforcé un dispositif appelé fonds
résilience doté de 100 millions d'euros
par les collectivités territoriales une
aide sous forme d'avancé remboursable
allant de 3000 à 100000 euros
ce dispositif est désormais élargie aux
entreprises dont les fonds propres sont
négatifs
cette mesure a été abondé notamment par
saint quentin en yvelines qui a voté en
juin dernier un plan de relance il
prévoit une enveloppe de 2 millions
d'euros en faveur des tpe et pme du
territoire à travers trois dispositifs
l'abondement du fonds résidents de la
région et du fond initiative saint
quentin en yvelines puis le financement
de l'exonération de loyer pour les
entreprises occupant des locaux de
l'agglomération
alors d'après un directeur un de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines saint quentin
en yvelines sera forcément aux côtés des
entreprises suite aux annonces du
président de la république peut être
probablement pendant le 2ème confinement
et forcément il travaillera avec le
département et la région ile de france
aymeric de la boissière par l'aide était
gelé
les garanties par l'état qu'est ce que
c'est ce dispositif rappelez-nous
nicolas le prêt garanti par l'état est
accordé par les banques aux entreprises
qui le demandent les banques étudient
les dossiers des entreprises et il est
garanti par l'état c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'y a aucun risque pour le bol les
banquiers il doit être remboursé un an
après l'obtention les entreprises
peuvent le demander jusqu'au 31 décembre
ça aussi ça a été rallongée par le
gouvernement si on doit faire un bilan
dans les yvelines d'après les chiffres
du ministère de l'économie des finances
et de la relance du 16 octobre
dix mille trois cent soixante dix huit
entreprises ont bénéficié de ce
dispositif dans les yvelines 95% sont
des tpe et pme et ça représente une
somme de 2 milliards 124 millions
d'euros attribués aux entreprises
parmi les secteurs d'activité
bénéficiaires 20% sont du commerce de
réparation d'automobiles et de
motocycles 13% l'activité spécialisées
scientifiques et techniques 12% dans la
construction et 10% dans l'hébergement
et la restauration
avant de vous donner la parole nicolas
landry je vouvoyais réagir aymeric de la
boissière
le pge est prorogé jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
transgene exact est encore donnée bruno
le maire a annoncé qu'il reportait
jusqu'au 30 juin de manière à pouvoir
laisser une nouvelle opportunité aux
gens de pouvoir emprunter et vous
souhaitiez de lui poser une question
alors je disais que s'il ya aucun risque
pour les banques est ce que c'est
vraiment réel alors
il reste 10 % malgré tout mais c'est
vrai que contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
croire et ce qu'ont pu donner les
chiffres puisque nous avons distribué
120 milliards de crédits à plus de 580
1000 entreprises
il y à une analyse qui a été fait à
chaque fois quelques dossiers ont été
refusés très peu
la médiation du crédit a permis de
mettre un peu de l'huile dans les
rouages
aujourd'hui nous avons il faut bien le
dire pas beaucoup d'échecs
la trésorerie a été souvent placé on a
bien vu dans nos établissements que la
courbe des placements avait suivi un peu
celle des crédits avec un petit écart
l'appréhension et l'inconnu elle est en
mars prochain de savoir comment ça va se
passer comment les gens vont est en
mesure soit de rembourser la totalité du
crédit puisqu'ils ne seront pas
utilisées soit de commencer à essayer de
l'amortir là ils ont quatre ans cinq ans
pour amortir le crédit en fonction de ce
qu'ils auront défini en fin d'année avec
la recharger clientèle sachant que
l'amortissement finalement c'est le
remboursements indus du crédit si les
entreprises ne peuvent pas amortir si
des entreprises sont encore plus en
difficulté encore fragilisé par le
deuxième confinement qui semble être
réfléchie imposé par le gouvernement
qu est-ce que ces prêts garantis par
l'état peuvent se transformer en aide
directe de l'état c'est à dire que
finalement l'état vient rembourser ce
que les banques les banques ont donné
aux entreprises alors à cet instant
précis cela n'est pas prévu comme ça le
crédit pge s'amortir a classiquement si
je ne peux pas remboursés j'entre en
procédure de contentieux j'active m'a
garanti et la banque reçoit sa garantie
ça contre garantie de l'état
en revanche est à l'étude et là deux
ministères d'économies et la fédération
des banques travaillent sur un crédit
qui pourrait être un crédit qui serait
un renforcement en fonds propres donc là
ce serait octroyé par les banques avec
une autre garantie et ça permettrait de
renforcer les fonds propres des
entreprises en france et on sait que
c'est un des points faibles des
entreprises françaises les fonds propres
ne sont pas assez importants mais vous
qui êtes au contact des entreprises
dites nous dans quelle situation se
trouve aujourd'hui que dans quelle
situation se trouve vos clients
entreprise alors je serais tenté de dire
aujourd'hui jusque là tout va bien
jusque là ça va on a eu quelques échecs
alors les gens qui ont été plus d'impact
événementiel l'hôtellerie la
restauration tout ce qui
avec de tourisme et là vraiment ça a été
très important néanmoins s'il y a eu
quelques cessation d'activité m'avait un
flux d'activité qui semblait repartir
après j'ai entendu parler dans
l'automobile les ventes de voitures tout
ça reparte et ce confinement
on est très inquiets et on aimerait bien
on va attendre ce soir pour savoir à
quelle sauce on va être mangé la
tendance on a compris et est la reprise
là vous craignez on le disait tout à
l'heure une nouvelle nouvelle crise une
deuxième vague de crise réussie on a un
coup d'arrêt ça va être problématique
pour tous les commerces de proximité
tous ces gens qui sont pas encore
passées sur internet tout ce qu'ils
avaient pu mettre en place des sites
internet et une vente à distance c'était
très bien tous ceux qui sont restés en
local un proximité ça va être
problématique
vous souhaitiez peut-être à bord d'un
autre question peut-être est-ce que
cette crise économique qui peut se
transformer en crise financière ah non
non aujourd'hui le système bancaire est
costaud on a des fondamentaux qui sont
très très sûr on a régulièrement des
tests qui sont faits par la bce et des
autorités de marché on nous a même
encouragé à réduire un peu nos et à
durcir nos critères d'octroi sur les
crédits immobiliers le hcf nous a
demandé d'être de revenir sur des
fondamentaux 33% 25 ans maximum pas plus
de financement à 100% donc ça va
restreint à bôle crédit ça va rassurer
les bases des établissements les
particuliers que les entreprises
non les entreprises on continue à faire
notre analyse personnelle c'est-à-dire
que chaque établissement analyse le
bilan les perspectives le marché la
capacité du chef d'entreprise à gérer sa
société et on reste sur ces mêmes
fondamentaux est justement une restreint
de seconde qu'en est il des particuliers
on a parlé beaucoup des entreprises est
ce que alors le marché d'immobilier
continuer à croître le marché du crédit
conso continue à se développer
de ce côté là on n'a pas de soucis on a
tous moyens qui restent très bas même
qui remonte un petit peu parce qu'on
était sur le crédit immobilier à 1,29
mais on est en juillet on est à 31 en
août ce qui est plus difficile d'obtenir
des prêts aujourd'hui alors jusqu'à
présent ne l'était pas je pense que
faire la fin de l'année il fera un peu
plus compliqué merci à vous et moi de la
voici
être passé en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le président du comité des
banques des yvelines pour la fédération
bancaire française et merci également
nicolas landry de la rédaction de tv 78
[Musique]
avant de continuer à parler d'économie
nous évoquions tout à l'heure les
difficultés rencontrées par le monde
hospitalier face à cette deuxième vague
de qu'ovide 19 regarder cet appel est
lancé par thomas l'aurait directeur de
l'hôpital de la porte verte un
établissement de santé privé à
versailles le site a besoin de renfort
en infirmiers aides soignants pour
épauler les équipes une deuxième unité
de médecine collier de 19 a été ouverte
depuis quelques jours sur place dans
cette crise du coronavirus la question
des tests est primordial pour détecter
les cas positifs les cas contacts aussi
à les isoler à saint germain en laye la
municipalité va acheter 2000 tests
antigénique ils sont capables de
déterminer en quelques minutes seulement
la positivité d'un individu est la
commune souhaite mettre en place un
centre de dépistage pour les habitants à
partir de lundi le lieu n'a pas encore
été communiquée ces tests pourront se
faire gratuitement et sur inscription si
l'opération fonctionne elle pourrait
être reconduite
et alors que l'on annonce un potentiel
re confinement avec aussi un
renforcement de l'autre côté du
télétravail la solution du coworking
autrement dit d'un espace de travail
partagé près de chez soi pourrait
s'avérer être efficace afin d'éviter les
transports bond est en pleine épidémie à
saint-cyr-l'ecole un nouveau lieu du
genre a ouvert voici un mois bixente
maria santisteva un salon lounge
aménager trois bureaux trois salles de
réunion haas ancien l'école aéro fils
propose différents espaces depuis le 27
septembre
ils permettent d'offrir des services
variés à sa clientèle haute où on a
trois salles de réunion donc une petite
salle de six à huit personnes
une deuxième salle qui peut aller
jusqu'à 20 personnes et une troisième
que peut aller jusqu'à 30 90 parce que
19 personnes en conférence tant que
jeune entreprise on peut pas se
permettre de payer des locaux
et appuyer un loyer pour un bureau donc
c'est plus sympathique à louer un espace
comme celui-ci éviter les longs
déplacements pour privilégier le
télétravail l'offre semble adapté à la
période de restrictions sanitaires que
nous traversons chiant en télétravail
depuis novembre il ça dure un peu et
parfois on a envie de changer de sortir
un peu de chez sa session quand il ya 30
personnes ce n'est que des années dans
un espace beaucoup plus de monde et
éviter notamment des transports
c'est pas évident tout simplement de
travailler chez soi parce qu on est tout
le temps amené à faire les tâches
ménagères et travailler en même temps
c'est pas évident donc si bien aéro fils
aussi parce que on peut accueillir à des
clients tout simplement aéro fils
propose également des cours de yoga pour
allier travail et bien-être ainsi qu'un
cours de salsa le vendredi soir les
tarifs pour les espaces de travail
aménagés varient de 15 euros la
demi-journée à 300 euros pour le forfait
mensuel et malgré la nouvelle crise
économique qui s'annonce on en parlait
il ya un instant sur ce plateau les
créateurs d'entreprise sont aussi
valoriser en premier concours
récompensant les porteurs de projets
dans le sud yvelines se déroulait à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
s'était organisé à la mi octobre par
l'association la fabrique retour avec
eléonore sinoquet justin brasier elle
veut devenir l'incubateur d'entreprises
du sud-yvelines la fabrique a organisé
le 16 octobre dernier un concours pour
les créateurs d'entreprises à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
objectif pour les candidats faire un
pitch en 90 secondes de leur projet et
répondre aux questions du jury pendant
10 minutes
sept porteurs de projets sur dix ont été
sélectionnés pour participer au concours
une réussite pour la fabrique les
compétences humaines elles sont là les
ressources sont là les les compétences
techniques logistiques matériel aussi
voilà il manque
il manquait plus je dirais qu un
incubateur la fabrique joue ce rôle
d'incubateur sur le territoire est là
pour donc accompagner les porteurs de
projets et être lieu ressource également
le jury composé de quatre chefs
d'entreprise aguerris devait donc noter
chaque pitch en fonction de plusieurs
critères comme la faisabilité ou la
crédibilité
le lauréat donc du prix du jury se voit
offrir une séance d'accompagnement pour
conforter son business plan ou conforter
son plan de communication et le jury a
en plus
décider chacun d'entre nous passions un
petit peu de temps avec le lauréat pour
regarder d'un oeil
on va dire à experts mais en tout cas un
peu plus aguerri
le business plan et le plan
communication ceux qui vont bénéficier
de ses conseils c'est arnaud et sa femme
porteurs du projet arlos koffi
leur but être artisan torréfacteur
remblier enlevant york a même une
distribution comme un confit trucks un
magasin de café ambulant c'est forcément
un plus d'être accompagné par des gens
de société qui fonctionne et qui est qui
sont en plus représentées à rambouillet
s'est aussi bien pour le réseau que pour
la réussite direct delà de la société le
lancement d'ares l'os koffi est prévue
pour février prochain en plus du prix du
jury la future société a déjà des
contacts avec de potentiels clients
depuis le début de la semaine la
rédaction de tv 60,18 s'intéresse aux
circuits courts dans les yvelines la
suite ce soir avec ses bouteilles d'un
litre 5 qui ont investi les grandes
surfaces francilienne depuis septembre
lutetia c'est le nom de la seule eau
minérale 100% régional issu de la vallée
de chevreuse et découvertes avec mélanie
poké elle a changé de visage lot de
chevreuse et au mois de septembre devenu
la lutetia la seule eau minérale
naturelle d'île de france
elle est aujourd'hui référencé dans
toutes les enseignes franciliennes en
2009 il a été fait un sondage auprès des
consommateurs franciliens
vis-à-vis de la marque chevreuse et du
fait que il au niveau l'identité les
consommateurs ne se retrouvait pas
forcément notamment vis-à-vis d'eux
voilà la localisation
chevreuse ou est ce que c'est la
livraison se fait dans un rayon de 150
kilomètres maximum l'eau puisée à plus
de 600 mètres de profondeur est entouré
à 90% de forêt à quelques pas de lusine
faible composition minéraux locales
s'adaptent vraiment à toute la famille
notamment
et on a on retrouve d'ailleurs sur
l'étiquette le loto
adaptés à la course à l'alimentation des
noues
aussi nos pieds faibles en sodium donc
elle s'adapte aussi à des régimes
spécifiques
là on demandait
une faible consommer
c'est vraiment bien
s'adapter à toute la famille le groupe
au jeu et propriétaire de la source
située dans la vallée de chevreuse
depuis 2013
aujourd'hui la capacité de production
est de 28 mille bouteilles à l'heure
elle est disponible dans deux formats 1
litre et demi et 50 centilitres pour
l'année 2020 t1 le groupe vise 80
millions de bouteilles produites sur le
site
et puis ce soir le paris saint germain
est engagé en ligue des champions 2e
journée du groupe h en turquie face à
istanbul basaksehir coup d'envoi 21h en
attendant le club de football de la
capitale ou plus précisément sa
fondation installé son village hier
mardi aux chaînés rocancourt est
l'objectif proposer des activités
sportives gratuites pendant ces vacances
scolaires le reportage de michael et
demi d'euros le village de la fondation
psg s'est installé aux chaînés
rocancourt le temps d'un après-midi
créée il ya vingt ans la structure
propose aux enfants de participer à des
animations pendant les vacances
scolaires
350 opérations sont réalisées chaque
année par le paris saint germain sont
des enfants qui ont entre 6 et 15 ans
qui peuvent venir avec leurs parents
leurs grands frères leurs grandes soeurs
vraiment de partager un moment en
famille et on est on est sur des publics
qui n'ont pas forcément la chance de
partir et il reste pendant toutes leurs
vacances scolaires chez eux donc l'idée
c'est de leur propre leur proposer un
petit moment festif ce mardi 27 octobre
une douzaine d'animations étaient au
programme
on doit faire la deux on doit mettre
d'aller vous n'est pas niée
mais on a aussi nos limites du boul le
maquillage les personnes les activités
soins aux issues de le projet éducatif
qui se veut pédagogique qui est la
culture des quatre stops et pédagogique
qui est la culture le numéro dello sport
l'histoire du club était également
présenté aux familles avec une seule des
trophées éphémère les anciens joueurs du
psg comme laurent fournier avait
également fait le déplacement
ça permet de revivre pour nos coûts des
bons moments pour les enfants de devoir
un peu que le psg a évolué la fondation
psg devrait continuer à sillonner le
département pendant ces vacances
scolaires un nouveau village devrait
être installé à magnanville ce jeudi 29
octobre au complexe sportif irma harry
faut c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant retrouver mélanie poké un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés qui
abordera ce soir la question de la
généalogie
quant à nous on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]